this podcast is brought to you by and
we're introducing Burger King we the
other day we were talking about chicken
sandwiches growing up oh my favorite my
favorite growing up on Saturday is we
used to go up there there was the Burger
King next to Michael's jewelers and we
used to go up down a girl Darcy buzina
used to help herself with buy like a
like that like a hamburger and she'd
give us 23 chicken sandwiches on the arm
I loved those chicken sandwiches but
guess what Burger King has the new spicy
Crispin chicken sandwich
that's one spicy chicken sandwich
actually that's two sandwiches I'm
talking about the new spicy crispy
chicken sandwich at Burger King and you
can get two for six dollars that's a
great deal that is a great deal for you
you know things are rough right there
it's a new spicy crispy chicken sandwich
from Burger King it's made with 100%
white meat seasoned chicken filet and
has a crunchy with a blend of cayenne
pepper and spices there's fresh lettuce
tomato cream email and it comes on a
sweet beautiful soft potato bun are you
kidding me or what and the best part of
the sandwich it may be the price because
right now the spicy crispy chicken
sandwich from Burger King is part of the
2 for $6 meal so go to Burger King right
now and get yourself two spicy chicken
sandwiches part of the 2 for $6 meal at
Burger King this podcast is all also
brought to you by squarespace turn one
of your cool ideas into a new website
you could showcase your work you can bar
blog or publish content and you can sell
product in the services of all kinds
promote your physical or online business
announce an upcoming event or a special
project and more those we're going to do
head over to squarespace.com for a free
trial when you're ready to launch and
use the offer code Church see you
si-hu rch to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or a domain that
squarespace.com at the code church kick
that [ __ ] muley oh [ __ ] big jon
in the house what up brother I can't
call it another great weekend in
paradise
here in Los Angeles thank you for coming
on Lisa at the man of [ __ ] Steel took
him three days to recover from the
mushrooms we are [ __ ] up lis we can't
keep doing that each other I'm cool
I'm sama bad influence Trevor you're a
young guy you gotta look after him and
all that hey mushrooms and [ __ ] [ __ ]
edibles I went to ballet ballet my
daughter goes on well okay so your
daughter was doing belly not you ballet
no no thank you which wouldn't be
wouldn't be bad is good for your balance
good for you
you were seeing a male ballets thighs oh
yeah strong as hell get [ __ ] like
things there used to be a Yankee that
was the Japanese guy remember a couple
years ago there was a Yankee the picture
no he was like oh hey Dickie Matsui that
came at Ruiz [ __ ] legs the muscles
you would see the muscles come through
baseball pants that's pretty intense
when you see that v oh yeah that's the V
you have to you like 22 that was just it
goes away Mets so we had that V at
[ __ ] 35 still what's up brother dude
I'm just look at just chillin out of the
referee game you have to put up with
that [ __ ] no more [ __ ] [ __ ] replays
and knees to the [ __ ] head I got a
deal with this [ __ ] no more your
Bellator you got a nice job you flying
the night before do you have to do the
weigh-in you know I actually I'm
actually had to fight a lot sooner now
than I was when I was refereeing cuz
when I was referring and sometimes I
come in day of the show and now I come
in if it's a fight on a Friday I don't
come in on a Tuesday I'm doing work do
fighter meetings and things on
Wednesdays do production meetings and
stuff on the Thursdays
do another freaking rehearsal on Friday
and do the show on Friday so really
interesting thing you said before the
podcast on it you're 55 and you and your
third career
that's exactly yeah that's what you know
when you look back at things and you go
how the [ __ ] did I get here
you know that I started off man I was a
dumb thug bouncer you know I bounced
were to make money and then I ended up
you know getting on LAPD and that was a
good career and I made a good career out
of it I was happy with it I met a lot of
good people got to you know do things
that were fun and then the reffing with
you know MMA just became something just
got bigger and bigger and better I did
that for 25 years you know till 24 and
now it's I get another chance to have
another career you know still working in
MMA which I love you know I will always
love it's a passion of mine but I'm a
lucky dude I am [ __ ] lucky good feet
yeah you make twenty years in the [ __ ]
twenty five years and as a police
officer that's a tough gig man if you
leave the house you don't know what dude
I could I could not do it now under
under the under the parameters and
things that they do now I'd have gotten
fired I gotta ask you a question on off
base here yeah did you know Charlie Beck
yeah very well in fact uh when I came
off probation I went to Southwest
Division Charlie Beck was my sergeant
how cool was he actually he was a good
guy then he was you know he was big into
racing dirt bike motorcycles he was in
the motocross and so yeah it was
something I did as a kid for a long time
so you know we would talk about that he
was a nice guy he actually had a his
father was really you know big on the
LAPD before he was a commander on the
LAPD and so that's all I knew of him and
stuff and then you know he went his way
and I went mine and he became the chief
now I would bet you know the new chief
that's coming up I one of my classmates
Beatrice Kamala is up for that job and I
I'd be surprised as she didn't get it so
she white black she's white but you know
what
smart girl was always a dedicated
towards being a police officer a seed
about certain things you know but a
climber she was definitely not like me I
and I was one of the dumb grunts I liked
being just the street guy or the guy
that was teaching and stuff that you
know I enjoyed that I didn't ever want
to be the supervisor I didn't want to be
the guy going around writing paper on
people so I never climbed going to meet
Charlie back you want me you haven't
forgive him on your podcast man you know
what I like him but I want to talk to
him man-to-man like about police issues
like I really like him a lot but I don't
like I like his eyes I like his face I
don't I [ __ ] hate when he has to make
a statement and he's contradicting
himself I'm gonna Columbus I know
Charlie
I don't do that that's who is Charlie
that's called politic these are police
captain she's a Chief of Police for LA
fellow cast on your right and I like
everything about him with this like I
like to go to his office one day as an
ex-criminal Oh Charlie let me tell you
what the [ __ ] I see on the street that
you guys are doing wrong that you're
what you focusing on and I want to hear
it let's hear it what he's focusing on
and what he should be doing it two
different things
Leanne died about two years ago I was
having surgery or something and Lee was
kind enough to drive it was a [ __ ]
Monday morning bumper to bumper traffic
by the time we get there you know who's
causing the traffic a [ __ ] cop now on
a Monday morning please do me a favor
all right you have a call but why do you
have to park sideways like this into the
[ __ ] Street to make people go around
into one lane on a Friday and when you
got there they were talking to a
homeless guy I could see if they want
pursuit of 187 you know a gang member it
[ __ ] like that that that you know it's
called common sense common sense and you
can't give it look at it's the one thing
that I learned men you know when I when
I was at the end of my career I was
teeth career I was teaching up at the
Academy and I would have 50 people in a
class 50 people and 35 of them would
have a degree and I mean a degree from a
be a BS to an MBA to certain people that
had PhDs becoming police officers all
right about 15 of them would be you know
either a military background or they
were just high school you know educated
but man the one thing I learned is I
don't give a goddamn how much education
you have if you don't have common sense
you're an idiot and these people did not
have the ability to make decisions they
could have this great educational
background but to make a decision now
they could not do it because they were
growing up in an in a time that was
different than when you and I did think
about when you were young and you
on the streets seven o'clock in the
morning you're out the door boom you
were going down to whoever Stevie's
house whatever it was Vinny's house and
you're out doing things you're out
making decisions and those decisions
most of the time were stupid as hell but
you made home and then you paid the
consequence form at times you know and I
did the same thing but through that we
learned we learn how to make decisions
and we knew you know what this is a
really stupid [ __ ] decision but this
is what I want to do and when you got
smacked for it you go I deserved it it
wasn't other people making decisions for
you you knew when you were supposed to
be when your mom told you I want you
home at you knew you were getting your
ass there at that time or you had
consequences and these people have grown
up nowadays they're growing up they
don't make any decisions their mommies
and daddies take them when they're gonna
play they have a play date they have
someone that's watching them the whole
time because we have this idea that the
world is so much more dangerous now than
it was when we were growing up when no
it's just more out in the media there's
more social aspects to it there's still
the same number of pedophiles out there
we have the same number of pedophiles
back in the freakin 70s they just
weren't on TV in the same context but we
were making decisions and those
decisions have now formed who you are as
a person at 55 and you can make
decisions now you make decisions as far
as hey that's a stupid way of going I'm
gonna go about doing this this way and I
learned through it doesn't matter what
your educational background is you have
got to start making decisions as a kid
play is something that we need out wean
our kids to play without parents
interfering because in play they make
decisions they're learning that's a good
part of what they need to do to make
themselves successful and when they
become adults and we don't we don't let
that happen and it shows and it shows
just like what you're saying you got
someone pulling over a homeless person
parking their freaking car in the
military blah oh my I'm a morning Durham
or now same things I feel that because
the media the police and society have
put
distance between themselves when I was
younger even though I was a criminal I
had constant contact with police cars
you had guys on foot beat where you were
at that foot beat I had foot beat and
like I was telling him a story when I
was growing up there was a cop in Jersey
I look like Phil Simms and he had the
beat by the high school and I had a
friend that bet the Giants one day and
Phil Simms [ __ ] up the game so he just
hated that cop on principle and he would
get drunk and look at Phil Simms and go
without that badge and that [ __ ]
gonna [ __ ] you up
this went on for years from the time the
kid was 16 and then one time when we
were like 17 my friend got into a fight
and Phil Simms actually brought him home
and he you know Phil Simms was telling
his dad what he did he opened up the
window and he's like dad [ __ ] him
I'll [ __ ] fight him right now tell
him to drop the gun Phil Simms as a
[ __ ] but it didn't matter
you had a relationship with Phil yep I
tried to walk in six months ago I had an
idea I have a child now you know I'm
concerned about different things kids
don't play on the street I went over
there Starbucks
meet a cop day at Starbucks so I went
down and I started asking the person the
cop is there no tal around here they
looked at me like I was a [ __ ]
Martian they go on what's the PA are the
pl is a building that every town has if
the cops [ __ ] go there when they're
off duty and they communicate with kids
and they have a PA L boxing me and they
had a pl baseball league you can go to
pls how do I learn how to shoot a gun in
New York Tyler I shoot pool they did all
these things they took you swimming that
gave the chance for kids to meet these
cops and build a bond you were never in
trouble because the PA L was right there
would taken off things now from law
enforcement that was so effective in the
70s like to be cop then you begin that
there's a beat cop that would walk from
[ __ ] Riverside and lancashire him all
the way up to where the movie theater
where the train station is right there's
two of them one from 8:00 to 4:00 and
one from 4:00 to 12:00 and he stops in
he is caught and you get to meet him Lee
this
different society you know the biggest
deterrent to crime is a cop with the
uniform on that's the bigger if I'm a
criminal and I know there's a beat cop
that's a deterrent I'm not gonna want
now
there's two types of beat cops when I
was growing up there were the beat cops
that they wouldn't arrest you they knew
your mother and they knew your father
take your [ __ ] beating on you I think
I can hear and there's nothing you you
wouldn't tell your mom Big John hit you
because then she called Big John and
find out exactly what the [ __ ] happened
so Big John had a relationship like Big
John man this area if we broke a window
big general come on though I'm not gonna
ask you guys but come on cross the
street go over to mrs. McCarthy's house
cut a deal you're gonna pay it back said
it was more community involved the
police coercion we don't have this no
more and so right now as Americans we
watch TV and all we see is negativity
from the police department they shot a
black kid they shot this guy they shot a
woman in the head who had three kids we
weren't there we don't know what the
[ __ ] happening but because the police
has distanced themselves from us we've
lost trust in them in a way in this
society are they busier now is like is
there a reason why they're stopping and
not doing all these programs now if you
look at just take a look at look at the
city of Los Angeles City Los Angeles 487
square miles and back when I first came
on it had 63 hundred police officers now
you figure how many of them are working
on us because you got certain ones that
are working you know different special
units and things like that but division
wise we had 18 divisions you've got
three shifts on each of those divisions
you can figure out on a given time out
on the streets of Los Angeles you
probably had 100 and you know 50 to 500
officers at the most at any given time
and you look at the distance they have
to travel they put them in cars because
that was the way to get things done fast
because that was the easiest way to get
the officers from one section to another
and they took away that whole
foot beats and took away the ability for
the officers to actually have
interactions with the community that
we're not bad because when you look at
you know when do you see the police
officers well it's I get these lights
coming up behind me and they're pulling
me over because now they're gonna say
that I ran a red light or I'm speeding
or whatever it is it's a negative
contact or I'm calling them because
somebody went and did something they
broke into my car broke into my home and
I got screwed over by them taking my
stuff and so I'm calling them and so
again it's a negative negative situation
that they're coming into and I'm not
happy to see them because they're not
doing me any good cuz they're not gonna
get me my stuff back and so every time
now for the most part it's a negative
contact that's occurring instead of that
positivity that was there when you had
officers that were able to go into the
community and talk with you know just
the citizens go to you know house to
house business to business and they knew
they knew that you know Bob works the
shift from here and they knew that Bob
would be there at a certain time they
knew Bob would take care of a problem if
they had a problem and that's the old
style that you were used to you know
growing up it doesn't happen any it's
even even even if he watched Dirty Harry
when he walks out he comes back and he
goes I've been coming here for 12 years
Susan knows I drink my coffee black
she's waiting on me a girl she got like
he knew there was something because he
went there and yeah
even the community knows when you're
coming yep so before I would steal when
I was a kid I knew what the top was on
the beat and what like I'm in one night
breaking into a house that I had broken
into three times when I was 16 and one
year and the cop live right on the
corner and the floor in the morning the
first time I got in there he had no
alarm the second time I got in there
here here know along with a third time
he had a [ __ ] like laser alarm and
this [ __ ] I'm like so I I go in
the alarm goes off and I run to my
buddy's house
and I go dog I got to get home and the
cops are gonna be there let me your
girlfriend cuz she lives in that
neighborhood let her walk me home and
then she could walk home and we'll say
we'll walk him then we were all together
and I'll never forget walking back with
her and that cop was with his underwear
over the road outside talking to another
cop and he looked at me go you break
into the [ __ ] house again [ __ ]
you know I told you one time we were we
wouldn't talk to we got for this pattern
we would go out at night and [ __ ] with
people like if we were drinking in that
parking lot and some people come over
and go do you guys have a light we start
talking to him and if it was four of us
we go you know you look I'm kind of cute
tonight if it was a guy and he'd go what
are you guys gay wanna suck your dick
we'd like say [ __ ] to him until he left
and one night with Tom this guy you know
what you look [ __ ] great tonight we
want a sudden get dick and the cop is
going one he's not offices these young
guys they want to rape me they want to
suck my dick the cop took a report from
the son he goes you stay right here
and he walked though it wasn't me I
should guys some I need this in my
[ __ ] life he goes I need this he goes
do me a favor he goes to the corner 12
I'm gonna drop this guy off it after 12
after I sign out of this [ __ ] if you
want to take him in the parking [ __ ]
when he asked that's on you but until 12
o'clock don't borrow [ __ ] touch it
don't touch him as well or take him
across the street because it became a
different jurisdiction the cops knew us
yeah cuz lewiston's kids that made you
think twice about doing something that
made you you know it get embarrassed you
in a way if I get busted he's gonna see
I got busted he was my baseball coach
the cops were more involved that was
pissed when I went to that police
station and talk to them after I went
through the visit the cop day at
Starbucks and I asked him I said they
like come down they treated me like I
was a [ __ ] Martian of that North
Hollywood station
so that is what is absolutely ridiculous
ridiculous totally completely it's like
the police should be working to get
people to want to know who they are have
them know who they are and to be part of
the community because look it you know
that everything that I did as a police
officer I was helped so many times by
people in the community little old
ladies that would sit there and someone
would say all you know I beat him up or
something like that and she would go oh
no no no I saw it all and she's the one
that kept me from getting in trouble
because it was my word against his word
now did I beat his ass yeah I did but
there was a reason he went and tried to
do something to me and that little old
lady would no no no I thought they'd
eaten that he hit him first and so it
took care of things and that was because
you know you would go hey take the time
instead of getting back in the car and
getting on the stupid computer and going
from one call the next takes the time to
start talking to people talk to the
people in hey how's everything going you
doing okay
you have any problems because all people
want I don't give a damn where it's at
everywhere I've been in this world most
people just want to work their jobs take
care of their families and be left alone
and I mean left alone from the bad guys
and left them alone from the police - as
far as they don't want to be stopped
they don't want any of that it's all the
same and start to get to know people
you'll have a lot easier time with your
job I learned how to deal like I never
ever ever had a beef with a police
officer oh I have just because I was
though my relationship with cops as I
was growing up the guy that adopted me
was kind of a cave as a detective he was
a rogue detective he was the mayor's
driver which man he could do whatever
the [ __ ] you want it so
you know one of my best friends growing
up was a cop plus when I was a kid I saw
how my mom's bookmaking operation how
the cop bookmaking what was considered
legal Mogollon the cops would even come
in and place bets think they were coming
and placed that numbers bets they were
Spanish they had the same thing so I
always knew when they come in to raid
the numbers thing they would sit us on
the couch
do that thing my mom will offer him a
drink it was [ __ ] hilarious now they
come in with guns drawn and the guns
again you know and they all day long
everybody know what time it was sit on
the couch we'll look around for an hour
go through your papers they go through
your [ __ ] papers but so I always I
never I was such a good criminal at one
time with such a I was such a good
that's why I ended up in prison no but I
was such a good from another I mean such
a well-behaved criminal okay when I was
around police that one time I got
arrested and I had a warrant somewhere
else and the cop picked me up and I
talked him into stopping at a Chinese
restaurant and he told me cuz I can't
believe you're eating this [ __ ] and I go
why there's gonna be good stakeout once
in there and when the lights were not we
could hear the rats they were like
people walking because I wouldn't need
in there but that's how good of a
criminal I always was like I was always
at least polite if I'd never ever ever
had a problem with cops ever even when I
got arrested I just keep my mouth shut
put my hands back get in the car what he
said nothing keep your [ __ ] mouth
shut
you know if he's nice you're nice I
never ever even even when I went through
the system nothing nothing you never had
a B for the [ __ ] cop yeah yeah I
don't know if this is everywhere but a
couple years ago I was driving through
like the canyons cold water and I had a
cop because Google Maps just told me to
go straight and I noticed as you're
going it's like between this time of
this time we can't go down here without
having a pass this cop pulled like three
people over he wasn't even in the car he
just had like an LAPD jacket on and
pointed out as to pull over and like
don't come down here again and I found
out later that it's just like it's an
area for rich like it's where the rich
people live and they I don't know I was
I was wondering I always wondered if it
was like a some sort of detail like how
that were like that's like so that's the
sort of stuff that would upset me about
cops is like stuff where it feels like
it's not fair or they're doing stuff
that but isn't like police work like
that but you he was he's trying again
for everyone a ticket for going down
that what he was on cold water he can't
give you a ticket for going down a
public street and that's and that's why
I thought it was a scam
because he all he he didn't have a
police his police guy was pulled over
and he just in the LAPD jacket on so I
thought like the neighborhood hired the
cop or something you know what certain
streets can do is they can actually
become private streets and they can
you'll see they'll put barriers up and
they'll put speed bumps inside and
that's because the the people there do
have money and they've said they will
take over and they pay a certain amount
to do things as far as putting those
things and they'll hire you know
security or something like that and it
could be an off-duty police officer but
until that's sucking that that sucker
has a barrier up I'm driving where the
hell I want on a public street see
events that's like the the confidence
that you have caused me like Joe like
Joe I mean I'm probably even more polite
than Joey just cuz I'm terrified well I
don't want to get I'm polite sighs look
at the one day here's one of the things
that's so funny yeah I used to do all
kinds of stuff with taking people that
were anti police and that's okay you
know I understand it everyone grows up
differently and you can have bad
instance you know a bad incident
happened in your life that makes you
feel a certain way about police officers
but I had people that would you know
they were in groups that you know
wouldn't you know protest against police
officers stuff and they actually came up
to the Academy because they're talking
about police officers shooting people
and why and there should never be any
reasons and I would put them through
scenarios and I would I would explain I
would put them through training that we
would actually do for police officers
and put them through scenarios and say
okay I want you to you're the police
officer and you're gonna deal with this
and they always always shot someone they
should not shoot okay because they got
Gared or they were killed multiple times
because they weren't gonna shoot and
they were just killed I smell it coming
out just making them leave and they're
going what was you're supposed to be the
person that is here to protect the
public when you have that person who's a
deadly start to poke you need to do this
job right and I put them back through
the same Center and they would screw it
up completely and finally they get to
the point I don't know what to do really
it's not that easy is it
okay there's decisions to be made but
the one thing that you know I don't care
who it was you can tell people look at
one of the biggest problems that we have
between citizens and police officers is
mouths be it the police officers mouth
or the citizens mouth and if you get
stopped by the police okay if I get
stopped by the police my hands are going
on the steering wheel okay I roll down
the window before they come up and my
hands stay on the steering wheel and I
say hello officer how you doing right
and they're gonna sit there and say do
you know that you whatever it was no
idea you know license and registration
okay my license is in my back pocket in
my wallet and my registration is in that
glove box and they're gonna tell me go
ahead and reach for it I reach for it I
get him and I give them to Sir just wait
right here and they go off you know the
first week out of his in Vegas firstly
the guy lived in Vegas I got stuck
pulled over for speeding and this is
exactly what happens and then you know
he comes up and he's got a ticket for me
and he says you know sir you know you
can appear on such-and-such state yes
sir he says I need you to sign here this
is you're not saving guilt and I signed
the ticket and I had a ticket he gives
me the ticket and I and I leave now am I
happy I got a ticket no but I am never
in fear of the officer doing something
that is going to hurt me if I don't give
them anything to fear in return it's
when I start to not comply why is it
that I'm not complying if you're the
police officer and you make this stop on
this car that's speeding all you know is
that you have someone that's speeding
but the person in the car could have
been someone that just committed a
robbery just committed a rape just
committed some type of
crime and when they get stopped by the
police officer in their mind why'd the
police officer stopped them for speed or
does it do they know what I just did
because you're always wondering what
does it what does the officer know and
that's the problem because now if you
are that person that did the crime
you're trying to weasel your way out of
trying to get certain indications it's a
whoa I haven't done anything and then
the officer starts to get more interest
in why are you not just doing the things
that I'm asking you to do and then it
leads to more you as the the so that's
the civilian if you just comply you give
the license when they ask it you do that
you never have to worry about ever
getting hurt by a police officer it's
when you start going off the rails and
deciding I want to be confrontational
congratulations you just put yourself in
a position where possibly you could get
hurt it's your choice I've seen it oh
yeah a thousand [ __ ] times and I mean
like I said I've gotten to the but
arrested so many times and I used to
laugh with the cops I'd laugh at them
like I'd happen laughs the next thing
you know I was in the thing with no
handcuffs on and gig one just because I
always grew up believe it or not with
him like the respect towards cops like I
really I grew up with that PA out when I
moved to Jersey
that's all I hung out with was cops and
I knew there were dirty cops and all
that I didn't get involved I looked at
the guys like I used to play isolate
basketball with this cop ray on that
stuff and we used to goof on him we were
16 he was 30 but he's always wear
colored socks and it would true me start
a mess though but mr. Mesner was a
[ __ ] great top and I remember one
night I went out for this party and my
friends made up they took all their
parents booze oh and put it in like a
bog garbage container and with heist and
they put it B's and we've all done that
Alistair and I drank some of it and I
woke up on Jimmy Cicero's front balcony
and it was mr. Nestor that woke me up
Coco you want a ride home and he gave me
a ride home and he's like he can't drink
you know this is how you feel when you
drink at least he tried to talk to me
and carried me up to my door you got me
you know I knew these guys I knew them
growing up and I had this so over the
years I could tell you thousands this
week but when I got out of prison I
wrote the arresting officer the two
arresting officers the judge and the DA
a letter an apology letter Wow okay and
my job was when I got out of prison to
keep in touch with the judge he gave me
a chance so I didn't want to prove him
wrong so I kept in touch with this judge
I wrote him a letter read 90 days
whether he [ __ ] read the letter or
not you know he read the letter
he read the letter and then I went in
front of him once during my divorce
he was now a civil judge and nobody
remembered and my ex-wife started saying
all this [ __ ] he lost I'm out here you
were the one that was in court three
years ago praises his [ __ ] things but
he would come in here and talk piece of
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] outta content the
court and it was because of that the one
arresting officer Italian guy like from
Spain he was in the he was involved in a
little girl murder in fact CBS just did
a show about a year ago about the little
girl they murdered in Boulder Johnny and
he was deep in that he was very nice to
me when I wrote in the letter I bumped
into him like three months later and he
goes I meant you [ __ ] up and you paid
you do for society the main arresting
officer
his name was Cola he was just us come
back huh why he just didn't see it but
he just I wrote him a letter and then
when I went to court with my wife he
backed my wife he showed up with my wife
and had new husband he never really till
this day like that no Jimmy Cola was a
detective that was involved in the
bottle [ __ ] in the JonBenet Ramsay there
was a different guy this white dude
until today if he would have been such a
good cop I wouldn't be here because he
didn't do the homework on me that dumb
[ __ ] he didn't do the homework I
was sitting there sweating bullets
dropped the whole thing he had made
contact with me a year earlier on a
completely different case
that could have hung me it could have
cost me another ten years and I split
town and when I turned myself in he was
through the he is now a detective and
the whole time I'm sitting there going
what is this [ __ ] gonna remember
me and I kept pulling the preliminary
hearing this I can I kept waiting for
him to draw up the old case they never
picked up the old case you know it's one
of those crazy things it's like people
change and they do they do change you
know they do and you can't I'm watching
this egg button and there's there's the
thing it's on CNN I never watched CNN
but also and I start getting people
calling me and saying man I'm seeing
your dad on TV oh yeah your dad your dad
was part of the this will you done this
yeah yeah yeah yeah and there's this
whole series on Patricia Hearst that
yeah that just came on what they call it
the [ __ ] dad was a cop yeah oh yeah my
dad was my dad's famous here in LA so
your dad was gonna shoot out with those
IRA people over there is SLA yeah yeah
even email let me tell you a story the
cop I told you about that drove for the
mayor when the feds raided his house
they found the machine gun that Patty
Hearst had Robert that's how deep he was
in Tanya yeah what was it called the
Turner I can't when something generation
something terrorist of Patty Hearst or
whatever was I don't know but you know
I'm watching that and they got you know
I can remember from my dad you know I I
remember you know he brought in the
pictures of what you know what the
people look like after all kinds of
stuff but I met I remember bill and
Emily Harris were two of the ones that
kidnapped Patty Hearst you know there
was a Donald to freeze they killed him
sink you he was one of the ones that was
that you know Willie wolf and six of
them died in that shootout but here is
William Harris Bill Harris sitting there
being interviewed about this whole
kidnapping Patty Hearst and everything
they were doing and you know the the you
know he talking about him going and
shoplifting at Mel's Sporting Goods and
when she fired 30 rounds over and you
always head
and stuff and I'm sitting there and I I
can remember when I was a kid that was a
bad dude man he was you know he was
radical he was crazy he was bad and I'm
watching it I'm listening to it I'm
going man time for Cabela's all of us do
because he's not a bad dude anymore and
he's just you know he's just a normal
guy who had freaking crazy frickin
radical thoughts back then and now he's
an older guy doing pee I work and you're
looking at it dude a lot of people
change not everybody but a lot of people
thank you I got the lead on now like
people accusing Dustin Hoffman of sexual
harassment from 1980 now that's predict
that [ __ ] even if he did it if it
happened in 1980 and you had an
awakening call them up and go hey why
did why didn't you say something by 1980
oh this way about what happened I'm not
gonna call CNN or me too because people
change yeah people really [ __ ] change
and I've seen you know I'm 55 I've seen
people make dramatic changes I've seen
myself change what I feel about now and
20 years ago what two completely
different [ __ ] people well that's a
very interesting thing you're saying
because being the son of a police
officer I wouldn't like it wouldn't
shock me and I wouldn't think poorly of
you if you were like I don't like I
don't like Joey he went to prison he was
a criminal for like like it's a weird
thing it's it's like it's like it's I
don't think I'll everyone has the
ability to understand that people change
I can see it would be easy to be like no
they don't change man people look at it
it'll change you make mistake who's the
person they can actually sit there and
go I've never made a mistake we all make
mistakes I mean come on man I've made a
lot of mistakes but the whole thing is
it's like man if you make a mistake be a
man being won't be a stand up woman and
say I made a mistake I understand I made
a mistake okay I'll take my punishment
if that's what comes with it or I'm
gonna learn through the mistake I'm
gonna learn how not to make that mistake
and I'm gonna move on and you got do we
all gotta move on in our lives it's it's
just part of the whole process of life
is
you are gonna you're gonna go through
just like I'm going through this my
third career that's a third different
stage in my life and hey people change
you've got to give people second chances
that's why though I don't appreciate I
didn't like that bother this whole thing
that was going on that people call him
when I was 14 you molested me chachi oh
yeah yes got my veils got got hey oh you
know he was just a man if you had a beef
if I see it on paper that you did have a
beef and they swept it that's a
different story but you watch that thing
on and I'm listening to him he's going
on Good Morning America and stuff like
that the girl puts out information
saying that she had sex with Scott Baio
long after Charles in Charge or whatever
the moot the show he had you know was
off the air and when he was on the air
with him it ended when she was 17 18
years old and she's saying she had sex
with him several years afterwards well
that makes her an adult I'm not saying
that he should have had sex with her I'm
not saying he's right but that's not
illegal and she's an adult at that point
and now she's trying to say no it
happened during the show and he's saying
tell me when tell me where all these
people are they're everyone you know it
this is not like oh we have you know
separate time you are watched by these
teachers and all of the stuff and you're
looking you're going why are you why are
you bringing this up in this fashion
look I'm the first person I do not
appreciate someone like a Harvey
Weinstein who has power over people and
utilizes that power to do nasty things
to hurt their lives or to hurt their you
know their personas in their the the
person that they are by making them feel
like if they don't do something that he
wants he's gonna take things away from
them
that's a nasty individual and he needs
to be dealt with any any you know female
that was assaulted by him I feel bad for
I'm sorry but when you have a situation
where you put yourself in that and now
you want say well I was underage it's
like why didn't you say something back
you know come on nothing drives me crazy
in that and that's what pisses you know
about this whole thing that I believe I
have I've seen people change like in
front of me I've seen people on Facebook
that were crazy and I wasn't one with 20
and now they're popping up with kids and
the kids are in college and they got a
job having kids changes your life tell
me it doesn't yeah it does yeah I did
you talk about funny I talk you don't
like Eddie Bravo I love Eddie and he's a
great guy and he's a crazy sucker and
then he ends up having a kid man life's
about his kid now life's about the time
he gets to spend with his kid and what
he gets to do and it's like look it's
you man you different dude that's
awesome
you know that's the way it's supposed to
be we all grow up and we figure out what
is important in life yeah when you were
younger when I was younger what was the
most important thing getting laid and
getting money okay money got me the
other things I wanted and sometimes
could get you late to but it was all
about man money was the most important
thing is money the most important thing
not having a 55 it's not you know I
figure it's telling me that's the other
day that when you get into comedy you
got you get so broke you get to a point
where you enjoy if you all the comedy
journey is not knowing what's gonna
happen all I know is that I'm gonna do a
show and pick up 50 bucks
that's all I [ __ ] know I don't know
nothing else when you get yourself to
that state of mind
nothing I've been so broke that when I
get a check now that the same way I'm
gonna do with this I've been so broke
for so long that and you when I was in
you're right we were talking we wouldn't
we're not saying that we need 25 you
can't wait to get money Oh is everything
and then you realize one day that you
can have all the money in the world it's
not gonna make you happy that you have
to make your own happiness you have to
promote your own thing it's it's a
different level of your life when you
come to that realization that you can't
do none for you you're happy in a hut
yeah I tell people all the time and
Liggett you know I'm never gonna be rich
and I don't care you know but the one
I've figured out and I've known some
very wealthy people you know the
Fertitta czar very wealthy people you
know Mark Cuban very wealthy person they
have all the money and they buy anything
no they can't you know what they can't
buy can't buy time especially time
that's gone by
you get 86,400 seconds every day and
it's how you spend those seconds of time
that's valuable because once they're
gone I don't care how much money you
have you can't get them kinda back and
so you figure out you know what look it
man spend your time times the most
valuable thing you have it's who you
spend it with what you do how you do it
with them that's what makes life special
that's what is important and you figure
it out yet look took me a long time to
but you figure it out over time took me
a whoa I thought that that was in it you
get money that was the answer all right
that was it and when they like no I have
no money but I'm still having a good
time I don't need money
yeah and I learned through comment like
[ __ ] surviving on 50 bucks and change
and eating Subway sandwich is the veggie
I was an LAPD police officer in
Hollywood that woman right there would
give me $5 I'm not [ __ ] kidding five
dollars for the week to eat on okay that
was what I got no I didn't say that I
used to gamble a lot and I would take
this thanks and that's how I would eat
too but man that was when I got to eat
because we were broke because I all my
money went towards my family and my kids
and keeping my kids in school and things
like that was what was important to me
but you know man you look at all the
things that you can buy property wise
man it's great to have the really nice
car man it's great you know if you get
the boat or whatever it is the nice big
house it doesn't mean anything
man you can't take it with you it ain't
going with you it's gonna break down
whatever it is is you know all of it the
people that you meet that you spend
quality time with and they do something
that alters and enhances your life
that's it that's everything that's what
you get out of comedy the people that
you actually get to go watch at times
before you do your set and the people
that you get to interact backstage and
even beforehand you guys are having a
drink in the step it's just that that
common bond that you have with each
other and you're talking about doing
something and someone's up there doing
on the stage and then you're listening
to me man that [ __ ] had something
going there that's the part of life man
that's it
that's the special part and that's what
you got to realize I do the same thing
with refereeing and telling people I've
said it too many times but man the the
part you're never gonna be rich again
all these people how much money can you
make the reffering nothing good trying
to make money you ain't gonna happen but
you do get certain things out of it that
are priceless you get to walk into these
giant arenas no one stops me and I don't
pay for a [ __ ] ticket man I get to go
down I get to talk to Joe Rogan if it is
or I get to go talk with freakin any
fighter and I no one stops me priceless
it's because it's a moment that you know
what it goes up here and I remember it
and I can pull it back at any time and
it doesn't cost me a thing when you were
a cop did you love being a cop I did
we had the jujitsu school did you love
running a Jitsu school yes when you were
a referee when you first loved it still
do and still miss it if right now if you
didn't have a wife and two three kids
would you referee for free I told people
all the time and you're I can't believe
they're paying you I am glad that they
don't realize that I would actually do
it for the problem that a lot of people
take jobs for money oh yeah they don't
pay when you're and they're miserable
they're [ __ ] miserable and when
you're a kid and you're a team and
you're going that's why I don't believe
that kids should make the decision of
eighteen to pick them five major because
they're gonna pick it from some kids are
[ __ ] just you know I'm gonna take a
sociology major you wanna be dead you
might as well shoot yourself that a
sociology major and all that I mean I'm
not putting nobody down I'm just saying
but then you have people who become
something and then after the four or
five years for seven years they go
I don't want to do this [ __ ] oh I want
to do this [ __ ] this is [ __ ]
miserable it looked good on TV you know
I'm saying they live like yeah and they
were having a good time on TV and it's
crazy how fast the world changes like
kids now if I had known when I had known
maybe I would have gone to build apps or
something or computer stuff I always
loved computers but it just from the
time that I graduated high school to the
time I graduated college now they're
smart phones and and all these things
that just didn't exist so it's you can't
the mother it's frustrating hearing you
guys say like oh money doesn't matter so
because I'm like slowly starting to
realize it but that was all the only
thing I can think about to you so I got
locked up when I was in prison money you
learned so much like once I went to
prison I learned one thing for sure but
I didn't want to go back to prison like
when you get to prison there's people
like hey what's happening mrs. Mack what
up
where you been oh I've been in what's a
big prison here at Pelican Bay okay I've
been in this how long you want to be
here but in this one I've been in this
one it becomes like a resume it's like
me it's like you sending me so what
movies every villain spider-man - the
longest shot you when you talk to these
people are in the walls mrs. Mac a
status it is the scariest [ __ ]
situation you know Johnny Mac over
Pelican Bay yeah we partied out one time
what are you talking about you weren't
[ __ ] prison with him what party now
no baby unless you show each other your
dicks what party did you [ __ ] have
yeah i party with big john up in Pelican
Bay on and the conversations I like
[ __ ] [ __ ] you like so you really
want to stay here but after a couple of
years you just get institutionalized and
when you go out they feel weird outside
they're uncomfortable in their skin you
know I'm writing a chapter in a book
right now it's taken me a long time
because I was trying to get the essence
of the chapter and that's when I got out
of County after being in County for a
month with kidnapping charge there's an
aggravated robbery charges and they
reduced my bail cuz they said other than
the contacts in the community and
ties for community but then my
father-in-law went in there and talked
to the DA he wasn't really my father I
was just dating his daughter but he was
a lieutenant colonel he went talk to the
DA he talked to the prosecutor he talked
to my attorney and they lowered the bail
of three thousand I got out it was
County Jail and for the first month well
I went through in my head was horrible
you know I fist my name came out in the
paper as far as the thing it was like
I'm the page nine but it still came off
the [ __ ] paper I thought everybody
read the paper so when I would go to
7-eleven I thought you knew behind the
counter that I had done that and then
almost dropped like it almost made me
gave up at times so I could see the
different angles of being
institutionalized but once I got locked
up I knew one thing I wasn't going back
I'll still do criminal thing but a buck
go below the line type [ __ ] and I'm
saying like mr. mean is if I get caught
like possession of stolen tools or
something like that something you know
possession is something but it's not
really not in my house I'll get him in
some way another it was [ __ ] crazy but
I made my decision and I don't know if I
was going to change and that you know
when I had the two felonies I I was
pushed into a bad position and I left
with my ex-wife and the boyfriend and I
left because I know he'll end up in jail
I don't wanna end up in jail not a good
place is ahead of the rest man you late
life's good you know life is [ __ ]
really poisonous but easy but you got to
work at it yes like anything yes you
can't expect it to just come to you you
got to work at it but to sit there and
look at doing something that puts you in
a place where you don't have a say of
where you can go and what you can do man
that's tough that's rough and to be in
prison you do get institutionalized
because you become so used to the system
you understand what I have to do to
survive in here what I have to do to get
along and that's who you become and then
when they if they do let you out scary
world out there it is and it's not
scaring the fact of all I'm worried
about people doing something too
now you're worried about how do I
survive without doing what I did put me
back there in the first place because
you know look at you do you know y'all
parole you gotta tell people you're on
parole
you know people don't want to hire you
now life just becomes rougher and
everything becomes harder and you can
sit there and say it's not fair and then
you or you can sit there and say you
know what doesn't matter how hard it's
gonna get I'm gonna I am gonna make this
work
yeah I going to survive I came on the
talon the background checks so I did
really [ __ ] good like I was I was
still doing all that [ __ ] when it took
30 days to get your fingerprints from
NCIC all right like it wasn't on a
lately I was looking up all the year
ahead of time to help you so like I
remember one time I got arrested for
shoplifting when I was out on bail for
the kidnapping I spent a month in jail I
know all these cops they call me Joey
but for that name I gave him Jimmy
something I gave him a friend of Mines
name like growing up they were calling
me Joey Joey good to see you they were
fingerprinting me and I'm looking at the
card that's saying my alias on it and I
bailed out that night without an ID I
got a friend to call I manipulated her
on the phone to come down and bail me
out under my name and then I went to
court under that name and I did the
community service under that name and
years later when I got arrested I was
looking at the paperwork in court are
you gonna and they had the alias on my
okay
oh it came up and now you're [ __ ] dead
you get arrested right there boom it
comes right up oh yeah but I did I did
time with a guy in County that was
driving one day with his wife and his
kid and some guy ran a red light and
killed his wife and his kid but he ran
away from the scene nobody can
understand why because he was wanted in
Florida for 22 years ago they arrested
him they thought he had alcohol in his
system he had no alcohol in her system
they let him his bail something
something was outstanding
and after a month it came back that he
was a guy that killed his wife so he was
sitting in there for 30
days before they even found that that's
how slow the computer was used to be
real slow paid bored going back and
forth so I had a couple hours google is
a [ __ ] now did you find out anything on
anybody man aka is anything the biggest
problem is sometimes you use these names
and you give a date of birth and it is
attached to you now forever and then
someone under that name where that date
of birth does something and boom it pops
up on that screen for that police
officer and guess who's going and you're
going yeah but look at new you're gonna
and it's like you play that game they
can come up and catch you in this
trouble I used to have fun in the 1985
I'm living in San Francisco and my job
was to put a suit on and sit in the
hotel lobby at the Hilton in the
Tenderloin
and I would wave for PM's rightfully
with the New York Times with glasses on
and I wait for people to check in and
I'd see what room they were coming into
and then people usually check in dropped
his stuff and leave but in San Francisco
they all had traveler's checks so I
would follow the main there was no
electronic cards the maid leave the keys
and the doors
I would creep up take the key out of the
door take the master key home mrs. Mac I
was hell on wheels and I would rob a
tourist Karl Malden man what American
experiment always was anyway warn us
call man don't leave home without him
don't leave home well here the streets
are safe if well my big thing was
traveler's checks because all you had to
do is take the traveler's checks to
Japan town but then they wouldn't ask
you for an ID so you had our traveler's
check you buy a hat that says San
Francisco for 695 to give you back
forty-three dollars in cash yeah it's
the same thing with counterfeit money
when you have 20s or 50s
you just go to bodegas in the Bronx
that's Bruns [ __ ] if it's you have fake
20s you give them a twenty for something
that's five dollars and you get fifteen
back you get all [ __ ] day long and you
do one area at a time so everybody goes
to bank the same day with fake money and
then you just can't go back there again
how do you get good at knowing like
who's telling the truth Big John cause
like if I
it's it sounds like a joke but it every
time I watch cops
I believe everybody I'm like they're
telling he said he didn't do it he's in
there and then they always like nine out
of ten times they did it oh my god like
how I don't know how you believe anybody
like house I've heard it all right the
cops never wrong you think that's crazy
wait till you go behind the walls that's
even crazier in vick's lying to each
other
I was a big shot I was in Mafia let me
bum a cigarette when they're saying he's
told me you won the [ __ ] money why
would you want a bum instead it's
hilarious how do you deal with that like
the bad cop good cop yeah my world
they're all [ __ ] line at the lips are
moving first year look at it it's a game
you know and so when you're looking say
now I believe everyone you usually you
know everybody's lying okay and most of
the time I'm gonna get information
beforehand so I know the answer before I
ask you the question
and so when you answer me I know oh you
are okay you wanna live see the problem
that would piss me off of the cop like I
don't know I don't know if I'd be able
to do it for 20 years just to have like
I'd be like everyone's lying to me I
hate everybody
though I like that like I get why people
get jaded if everything like that's your
you can before you can look at it it's a
game sometimes a game sometimes you lose
at the game but man don't get all
personal about it and stuff they're
gonna lie to you it's your job to set it
up to where if they're lying you can
make them look even stupider with what
they're lying about and now they're
gonna go away and you're gonna put them
and whatever the court systems do with
them they do with them don't take that
personal either
it's a [ __ ] tough job being a cop it
is I'll tell you now now I didn't do it
couldn't do it and it's ridiculous
officers to be everything they wanted to
be psychologists they're supposed to be
able to handle people that are bipolar
or that are you know having mental
breakdown
you're supposed to be able to take them
they want them to be physically able to
control anybody without hurting them you
know and trust me that ain't easy you
know and it's like I'm I was pretty good
and you know doing things and not
hurting people and putting on bad
situation that
positions but that you can't expect that
out of every one of them because all
police officers are different we're
different size different you know
backgrounds and some of us trained in
certain ways some of us don't they want
you to be superhuman and they want you
to put your life on the line in
situations to go to the absolute end of
everything by putting your life on the
line because this person could take your
life right now but you're supposed to
let that be out there so you don't take
theirs that's ridiculous I had certain
certain Qualls that I would you know
look at as a police officer it's you
know you had this Florida shooting and
you have those four officers now that
we're at the school didn't go in okay
you know all I can say is I hope you
have to live with yourself for a really
long time thinking about that because
you are a piece of crap you are supposed
to be the person that will put yourself
in front of others to protect them
that's the oath that you took I used to
tell people all the time there are way
words when I was teaching I would tell
people there are worse things than dying
dying is not the worst thing that can
happen to you obviously we all want to
live but to die doing the right thing is
not a horrible thing now I believed in
that I was taught that by my dad my dad
came up with all kinds of stuff that he
put in my head you know he had David
doggins now has it at 40 and my dad had
it before him it was the 50% rule and
the 50% rule was when you think that
you're done when you can't move when you
think that there's no air left for you
to breathe when you are absolutely at
your worst
you're only 50% there there's another
50% to go get going get busy do
something and that's the truth our mind
will quit on us long before our body
will and so you've got to be in this
position where you you have certain
things that you say I will not be the
person that stands
while somebody is attacking kids in a
high school and because I'm afraid I
don't step forward now how many cops I
had only read that there was one I
didn't hear about for four total now
well there was one who was like the
school police the school police officer
and like the first few deputies didn't
go in either yep look I taught that man
back you back when Columbine happen we
went said you cannot do what we used to
do which was oh we're gonna set a
perimeter around this problem and we're
gonna try to talk to these people that
are inside actively taking kids lives
your job is to get your ass inside of
that building find that sucker and make
it so they can't hurt anybody else that
is what you get paid for that is what
those parents expect you to do is it
scary it's scary I'm telling you right
now it's okay if you have fear fear is a
good thing fear tells you there's a
problem but courage is that element that
when you are scared to death you step
forward and do it anyways that's what
you get paid for to be as a police
officer in very specific moments of time
you have a choice make the right choice
do the right thing because Florida's
shooting obviously grabbed a lot of
people's attention
I mean you know as a parent I have a
five-year-old I don't know what the [ __ ]
I'm thinking now I don't know what the
fun come thinking you know do I move to
Tennessee this could happen anywhere
this could happen anywhere at any time
any [ __ ] school but as a parent now
what what do you do what are we gonna do
I mean I'm saying
the NRA I'm I'm hearing all this [ __ ]
listen I could buy a gun in ten [ __ ]
minutes I'm a felon I can make one call
have a gun here in ten minutes or I
could walk to the handball court is
that's where you buy the best guns are
at handball courts nice and used they've
killed eight people already
small 50 those [ __ ] don't miss
okay if you get quality you're gonna get
to charge rate different murders I mean
what giggling here and stuff but this is
the reality of this this is the [ __ ]
we are I get a gun right now but those
are twenty minutes and if you give me a
couple days I'd get a machine gun once I
get into the Armenians I could get
anything just give me a couple [ __ ]
days so obviously that I know what the
answer is what's the answer - the answer
is to put a Rambo in every [ __ ]
school you know Maya I'm a redneck at
heart and my brother-in-law's from
Tennessee you know he's a country and I
was talking to him the other day he said
this little girl asked him daddy wire
people shooting kids and he goes cuz
there's nobody there to shoot back at
him that is like it and the more I think
I like answer I as much as you're
opposed to guns or in favor of guns to
me in my mind that's the answer these
little [ __ ] maniacs gotta know this
little Martian they gotta know they stay
going there they're gonna get shot with
one of those bottle rockets that Rambo
had number pull the arrow and the
[ __ ] guy blew up like that's what
you're gonna get assaulted with it's a
bazooka right to your head oh you know
for number two we got a New York what's
that act that if I get caught with a gun
I get two years to the whatever act if I
get caught in New York City with a gun
there's no bail there's no going here at
New York State right New York sighting
we got a raise twenty and mandatory I
gotta give it to you I gotta give it to
you this is how this is gonna stop we're
always gonna be able to get guns
absolutely but how are we gonna stop I
can't you with a gun it's 20 men minimum
I think the imposes drugs in like 85 97
they doubled up on the drugs heroin
same thing with weapons no double up on
20 25 [ __ ] years you get caught with
an unregistered handgun or something
like that you know they're gonna we're
gonna change the age to 21 we're gonna
do a background check you could take
that background check and wipe your ass
with it won't take that [ __ ] and wipe
your ass with it they're still gonna get
guns but you guys both have more
experience with guns than I do
six months in Israel and they have army
and metal detectors everywhere so like
half of me cuz like yeah you can get a
gun anywhere but like those 21 year old
those 20 year old kids might not know
about the handball court so I think I
think it has to be both ways I don't
have a problem with putting an army
person at the thing but I think it has
to be a little bit harder to get a gun
I'd make it just a little bit harder my
friend sent me a video he's a cop he
sent me a video the school shooting in
Florida when they were taking the kids
out of the classroom and the teacher had
the towel on a [ __ ] head and there's
a puddle of blood around and the kids
have to run out and then when he was not
for the whole way there was a there was
cops in the middle of the hall and they
told the kids to hold on to the wall
touch the wall don't look you could see
kid's sneakers they got shot out of that
[ __ ] sneakers well I saw that that's
it like no kid deserves to see that at
that age nobody they're not gonna
recover from that some of them are but
fifty percent of those kids gonna be
[ __ ] up by seeing that on the floor I
don't want my daughter to see that big
job I don't blame it I don't want half
of the kids in this country to have to
see that what's the answer do I put a
[ __ ] Marine a [ __ ] guy right out
of North Carolina you know out of every
school that I look at it and there
there's no perfect answer to anything
okay but the thing is as a country we
cannot have our schools being attacked
can't have it no and so we have all
these things that we do and we have all
these programs and we help this country
in that country okay that's great we
need to take the money that we create
through taxes and start to put people in
place in every damn school while it is
in session that if that's taking
military personnel that is now leaving
the military and training them and
putting them there great if it is look
at the it you had the one guy who was
the football coach who stepped in front
of students and took rounds
okay and and losing his life look it I
think it's horrible that he lost his
life but goddamn it I love that man okay
I love him too he did what he knew he
had to do because he couldn't stand by
and do nothing that's the person look
I'm not saying arm every teacher out
there you can't do that because many of
them that weapon with them would do
nothing because they're afraid to use it
but there are plenty but there are
plenty of ex-military X law enforcement
people that are teachers that would say
I am willing to carry a weapon on the
school and I I know since they are
personalized with those kids they will
step forward because it's not only that
they know the what is going on is wrong
they know those kids and they cannot
stand by and let those kids get hurt
without doing something and that's the
person I need I need the person that
isn't gonna stand outside like that
useless sheriffs that were there I need
the person that's going to step forward
like that football coach and do what
needs to be done to stop someone from
hurting the kids you got to have it it's
it's done I mean we've had it too many
times now that we've had mentally ill
people and look at this kid in this in
this shooting look it they knew they had
too much information they have a guy
he's he's threatening people with guns
he's doing all this stuff you know he's
got mental issues and we don't do
something to make sure that he doesn't
have access to those guns we don't take
those are you [ __ ] kidding me
you know everybody down there that
didn't do something knowing that this
kids a problem shame on you
you're responsible you you you are
absolutely part of the responsibility of
what happened that's cool you're
supposed to be there to protect the
people that can't protect themselves
that's the job of a police officer you
know it's no different than the job of a
referee and fighting my job is not to
sit there and just enforce rules it's to
protect the fighter that no longer can
protect themselves let me get you out of
the fight so
okay it's just a fight it's not that
important but when it comes to our kids
and going to school you can't have
someone like you Joey a father releasing
his child into that school and having
fear that someone might come and attack
her at that school that's something no
one can live well no one can sit there
and just think about that and feel
comfortable that's it's with Tony
Bennett
I'll be back to me go tinkle cuz I'm
good they live go baby my little thing
is small alright let's talk about some
better stuff now let's go all Google
congratulations we're in your new
position thank you so much brother I
appreciate that
that was when I heard that was like god
damn what the [ __ ] did a thing with her
well once you got here you explained to
us that you know he got hold this is a
little easier for you a little less on
the joints and [ __ ] flying every
weekend what do you think man I I look
at it and it was one of those
opportunities how do you turn turn it
down I mean when you sit there and you
talk about me reffing so I loved it and
still doing do I miss it absolutely I
was given the opportunity to be a
commentator for one of the biggest
organizations there is in MMA I'm not
gonna sit here and lie to someone and
tell them the UFC is not bigger than
Bellator it is it's more well known and
everything but Bellator is probably
number two and I get to be the color
commentator for that organization that's
something that people work years to try
to get and I am given that opportunity
how do I turn that down it just I looked
at it and being that I am older I had to
neck operations within two weeks you
know that really screwed me up and you
know the middle of last year and stuff
and I was like man I just can't do this
the way I was doing it before as far as
the travel and everything by working
with Bellator it was going to cut my
travel down considerably and it was also
going to be that I was working you know
instead of working I think I worked 86
shows last year
be working maybe 24 how many shows the
bells of - a month - do they usually do
about two a month and all their fights
are on paramount all the fight oh
there's no more strike now that's you
now spike turned into the paramount
Network and it's got more I guess girl
friendly stuff what spike week the spike
was supposed to be a man channel you
cutting out 50% of the populations
that's pretty stupid that doesn't make a
lot of sense and so so 241 and 241 is
the paramount network I thought so
that's the only channel they fire on
they do do a pay-per-view events right
they've done two pay-per-view events the
entire time they've been in existence
they did one god I think it was a
Bellator one 102 or 120 or something
like that and they did the New York City
show that they did from Madison Square
Garden they had that as a pay-per-view
also they put on you know the fights
that they put on when they did the
papers pay-per-view they were great
fights look at Bellator has some great
fighters well one of the funniest things
I just saw is a1 one of the websites put
out a thing about what if we could trade
fighters and promotions and it was
hysterical because all the fighters that
they were trading from the UFC we're all
old fighters you know it was Robbie
Lawler and talking about how it will the
will trade you know
Peniel Dell Roush was not that old a
fighter but an older fighter and then
then it was all older front and all the
young fighters from Bellator was the
ones that we're gonna go to the UFC it's
like because they have all these young
studs and you go yeah that trade
wouldn't happen dude I'm sorry man yeah
the Bellator as far as like certain
weight classes they're 145 pound
division is stacked I will take the you
know you can take the 145 s in the UFC
which is fantastic and you could put
Bellator is right next to it man those
fighters can they can just mesh in very
well you look at the champion at 145 in
Bellator is Patricio pitbull Ferrer he's
a freakin unbelievable fighter he was
you know he goes up and wait to fight
guys
he'll fight anybody you
Benson Henderson went up at 1:55 was
beating Benson you know beat him in the
first round beat him it was a beating
him in the second and broke his leg on a
kick and so fight was over but I mean
he's phenomenal as a fighter you've got
young guys like a.j McKee Antonio McKee
son Antonio used to fight fought in the
UFC
his son AJ incredible young fighter
Gallagher who's fighting out of SBG in
Ireland with Conor McGregor he's gonna
be headlining the show in April from
Budapest incredible young fighter Aaron
picot Aaron picot it was and a kid here
in California freshman in high school
wins States in wrestling decides he's
gonna go for the Olympics he misses the
Olympics by by just the skin of his
teeth one point doesn't go to the
Olympics is fighting for Bellator he was
wasn't he absolutely well daddy told me
buddies it does a stud that's right and
they got all these young fighters that
are studs you know and they have things
going they know what they're doing that
they obviously have some older fighters
too that they're utilizing because of
name recognition like rampage and you
know Chael Sonnen and bring in guys in
to fight at times but it's all about
yeah you want to see this guy guess
we're good we're gonna put this guy in
here so you can see him too because once
people realize how good the fighters
that they have are look at know Thor's
got some studs going right now I'm happy
I am so happy and honored to be part of
that promotion because they're they're
doing the right things for the fighters
like I was telling you when Joe was on
about eight nine months ago he won the
Bellator rant and I didn't really know
anything about Bellator just because
it's like Kyle MMA is growing so fast
right now
oh there's so many fine I see these guys
that take nine months off when they come
back it's a different world huh these
guys are getting quicker faster lie I
mean it's just a different world it's
moving so fast once I had the baby
and my workload in the podcast I watched
out a whole world to go man watch half
the cards I
absolutely you know following staff the
cards I used to bellator has to have a
Bellator tonight
to talk about what the [ __ ] they're
doing so like guys like me learn and
educate me who's I know Ryan bait is
that listen you know about or reminding
me of the old San Francisco 49ers when
they were winning all those years they
would sign people to one-year contracts
never win a championship with them
because that owner had a knack to
signing people that still had one more
or two more good [ __ ] years and and
you know what the UFC got rid of Mousasi
are no reason who I think is a
phenomenal fight who's worth Bellator
yeah he the Bellator now Ryan Bader is a
crime writer you know Davis there was an
instant hit I'm such a reasons well that
Rory MacDonald in McDonnell do how you
get rid of Rory MacDonald Rory MacDonald
answer that fight with [ __ ] wallet
Lauer how do you get rid of Roy that
it's like I Spit to the face like what
I'm one of the best fights in a decade
yeah and we're gonna have a no argument
over paper now so yes that's what I knew
is something weird but that's what and
they're picking up momentum little by
little you know I know about the Grand
Prix you know I didn't know that they
had signed Frank Mir I know about you
know uh Roy Nelson I know about mature
um came to the comments torment lighting
this telling me that he's in Bellator so
I know that they're probably gonna end
up don't good things they're doing all
right
little by little it slows things it's
like a finger in the ass you don't see
it coming I mean I'm saying but you know
it's there and that's what they're gonna
do and you know with all this [ __ ]
that's happening with the UFC not I'm
not stripping the belt there's always
drum
anything gonna happen in this game you
know I that guys anything can happen in
this game right now I don't want to tell
me why is Connor the champion or is he
not the champion to champion at 155 but
but it hasn't for Habib is gonna fight
Fergus Ferguson and isn't that for the
undisputed title I don't know what's
going it's undisputed title that's what
they said from what I heard the
one of the reasons why they wouldn't do
it is the new UFC game came out like a
couple days later without you knowing it
let's be honest
the UFC has a contract that has a
champions clause and if you're that
champion you can't go anywhere and Conor
McGregor made a lot of money fighting
Floyd Mayweather and he started McGregor
promotions and he's got all kinds of
people around him and one of the guys
he's got a lawyer that used to work for
the UFC that now works for him that that
lawyer knows those contracts Connors not
stupid kind of smart and if Connor gets
stripped of that title that that whole
champions clause goes down the tube
Connor can go do other things Connor
could be his own promoter Connor can
look and say you know what I like the
UFC but you know what they're taking
money that I'm bringing to the table
because people want to see me fight I
think I can put that on and make that
same money Connors not stupid
neither is Dana white and there's a
reason why Dana White has it stripped
Conor McGregor okay look it's a game
it's a game you know it's all it's a
business and I totally understand the
business part of it man you've got to be
smart about what's going on with
fighters is I can tell you I travel the
world and there are so many good
fighters around the world that are not
part of the UFC and that's not saying
anything bad about the UFC can't handle
those fighters because they have a hard
time marketing the fighters that they
have and a lot of these a lot of these
guys are coming from places they don't
speak English you know they're like
you've got khabib kabhi now speaks
English which is a great thing but
there's a ton of guys from Dagestan E
and from Chechnya these guys are killers
I am Telling You really grown and rush I
read tomorrow I got what to go let me
tell you so much for them I know of
fighters that are in Russia that can
compete with anybody in any organization
at any level right now they're that good
they could they can go and fight for the
championship of the UFC the champion
Bellator and I'll tell you what it's a
50/50 that they don't take it okay
that's how good they are but these are
the guys that are out there but you know
as a promoter you can only promote so
many people and so fighters are in this
position where they a lot of them have
gotten this thing they want to go to the
UFC because that validates them you know
then it's like it's like it's the NFL
because if someone is talking about MMA
and they go oh you fight in the yeah I
fight you know who do you fight for and
they say Bellator person might not hurt
a Bellator and so who's that but if they
say UFC all that ultimate find you I
recognize that and so for a lot of
fighters that's their end goal is they
don't care what they're getting paid
they want to get that validation like I
have made it it's the NFL it's the NBA
it's you know Major League Baseball
that's what the UFC is to them but when
you're looking at you know Bellator what
they do
Bellator allows the fighters to have
sponsors they allow them to all the
stuff like the UFC used to do but they
don't take any of the money they don't
take any money from the sponsors they
allow them to keep all that sponsor
money and everything
the fighters themselves can wear the
t-shirts and the hats during their walk
out or you know in the ring and stuff
and so that's a way for a fighter make
money when they talk about contracts
Bellator doesn't give them that show and
win they don't do that if you know if
you're gonna make $40,000 for your fight
it's not a 2020 that you'll get usually
in the UFC the UFC says well you get 22
show and if you win it's 20 no the
Bellator fighter gets you know it's
$40,000 that's what you're signing
that's what you get so you can go out
and if you lose the fight you're not
losing money in it that helps you I hope
that helps you a lot and these are
little things that you know either there
are differences in the company Scott
Coker is in charge of Bellator you will
not find any fighters that say Scott
Coker is you treats me bad I want to be
known Scott before I've known Scott for
god damn since 2001 I want to say he was
actually doing a kickboxing k1
kickboxing in Vegas
and Scott Coker is he's a martial artist
he loves fighting he loves the grandeur
of fighting he doesn't care so much
about titles he cares about what's the
fight that people want to see what's the
fight that I want to see and I love that
about him because he just wants to put
out the best fights you take a look at
what he did in Strikeforce and you take
a look at the fighters that he had and
everyone when you know Strikeforce was
out there the Strikeforce sucks you know
to the Strikeforce fighters can you know
flight with a UFC guy and you look and
you go really let's take a look at what
happened when the UFC bought Strikeforce
well they got like Nick Diaz back ok now
Nick it fought already in the UFC but
they had this guy named Daniel Cormier
ok he was a fighting for Strikeforce oh
now he's the UFC champion and has been
there for a long time as champion the
first fight you know first fight for
Cain Velasquez was in Strikeforce and
then he did a bro dog and then he got
signed to the UFC but he was a
Strikeforce guy and then Luke Rockhold
Strikeforce guy became UFC champion
tyron woodley Strikeforce guy he's UFC
champion you take a look at look there's
guys that know how to make fights and
knows how to pick out fighters that he
believes that's the guy that's gonna be
special
Scott Coker has an incredible eye for
talent and has made in great decisions
and who is gonna be that guy that is
gonna be somebody he knows fighting and
that's what's great working with him is
he has a passion for it the passion of
hey I can't do everything overnight but
eventually this is the direction we're
walking let's just walk it together I'm
happy it doesn't look like when we were
kids that had the NFL in the USFL yeah
and you knew the USFL wasn't gonna make
it like you ain't anyway Omega they
didn't make it
yeah Trump on the Jersey Jersey general
but you look at who it was playing for
man Herschel Walker sure watch or walk
there so I'm Adam Doug Flutie Doug
Flutie then yeah they were playing for
me at Steve Young here in LA with the LA
Express man look at there was some great
Reggie white played for the Philadelphia
stars they had some
great players in the USFL saw no no I
think that you'll do great there because
they are growing like I said I'm just I
don't know what the [ __ ] is on no more I
don't know like it I come home and then
I come to TV on all UFC tonight on I get
to watch a little bit of that that's
know why that's great I watch a
countdown show once in a while it was
shitty for a while now this week's was
pretty good were frank yang do it but
that's gonna be a great fight I just
gotta get more knowledge about Bellator
and then I'll have you back and we could
[ __ ] go back and forth now more
[ __ ] up I don't know nothing about him
but I just know a lot of fighters went
over and and I couldn't figure out why
Dave they let a lot of these guys like
like Mousasi was one guy couldn't figure
out but it's like a common key but
Mousasi came from Strikeforce
Mousasi he was in Japan fighting a
little bit and then went to Strikeforce
and he really like Scott Coker and you
know he was part of the whole when they
swen Strikeforce got sold there was
reasons why Strikeforce got sold most
people don't know what it is
okay but Strikeforce you know Scott made
a play to get bigger and brought Silicon
Valley sports into play they were the
owners of the San Jose Sharks and all
that and when they made that play to get
bigger you know there was a lot of money
that went out and then they didn't get
their return like they thought right
away and then they decided we want out
of this and so that's why they ended up
getting sold it wasn't as Scott wanted
to sell it
it was Silicon Valley sports wanted out
of it and so the four Titas being smart
lorenzo goes up that's a lot of
contracts and those are great fighters
and that's something's gonna help us and
he went out and he paid a lot of money
for it and you know hey that's what made
Lorenzo Fertitta so special he was
willing to spend money to make his
product better and he did and he use a
special owner and he's gone now
but you know he made the right right
choices on what he was gonna do then you
were a kid and you would doing taekwondo
whatever
or you don't did you ever think that the
UFC and all this [ __ ] you see it coming
I didn't see it coming at all as I
turned around one time and some guys
built like me with two tubes on hitting
each other I'm like this is the most
disgusting sport and my life this is
just bar fighting for [ __ ] criminals
and [ __ ] and I thought I just didn't
watch I was a Bruce Lee guy I watch the
two fat [ __ ] clone punches at each
other you can't tell that guy just hey
the [ __ ] pharmacy full of steroids
that guy just came back though first
time I flew I didn't know their names I
don't know who these guys are
I saw a guy in the UFC one night
remember Joe took me to Miami nobody
showed up
yeah LA fool yes he 42 yeah who showed
there was a celebrity though in the
house
it was [ __ ] empty the guy from Hawaii
for it
oh come on Japan no I'm the guy that was
knocking people out fat dude he was like
the biggest thing in the US oh yeah
[ __ ] cabbage cabbage that's who I that
was the honestly Korea [ __ ] Rogan
would clumped me about the UFC and I go
stomping already like I thought didn't
like it then he got the man show and he
goes come to a sketch in Florida and the
ER season to be there for him and I went
and I'm looking at cabbage his body I'm
like what is this listen II would be
spinning in his [ __ ] grave right now
really couldn't have done anything with
calves you gonna hit it with everything
you had oh my god the hell and then I
didn't watch it today with him and Eddy
and Tate would sit there in the car and
they wouldn't shut the [ __ ] up but I'm
like these bumps and then one night I'm
at home watching TV and I turn around I
see and this and silver kicking the [ __ ]
out of a kid I'm all those fight nights
at the Palms and I was like I like that
[ __ ] day and that was it that's how I
got it all it takes his Mormon once I
saw Scott why did also see the the you
know the big big fight the one that set
up I had watch that my mistake frankly
talking against talk about Franklin
against silver or are you talking about
no oh you talking about Forrest Griffin
against Bonner I saw that fight and that
was like
okay there might be something here maybe
I just caught a good fight and then I
would talk to Joe and asking questions
and then I saw him this time I had
almost blew up yeah I was like that's
that's the [ __ ] way to do it now I'm
a fan but like I'm happy in a way you're
not [ __ ] a referee no more because
you can't win especially at the end
tonight
you can't [ __ ] win you can't win
people always gonna be up I [ __ ] hate
the Internet and I hate what it's done
to people's lives I hate it social
medias awesome it's awesome because
everyone knows everything but it gives
people the right to talk sometimes that
don't know what the [ __ ] they're talking
I'm on it drives me [ __ ] crazy that's
all they do
I don't mind if you open up your mouth
you know if you're gonna question a
referee or question a football call or
questioning something I don't mind it
well if you don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about
don't [ __ ] question it like that and
I see it every Sunday when you took
Facebook up during football season what
happened this year with New England they
could they burnt somebody like game 12
with a bad cows and Steelers and yeah
the Steelers and I you know the next day
they're whining it on there and I'm
taking about these referees and the two
[ __ ] so I bet that party was great
like this last week we had that
controversy with Jeremy Stephens let's
go to Bloody Elbow so my man can break
it down for us cuz I don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm talking Mike white told us I
don't know the point system and then you
punch him in the head you take him down
but I don't know how the point system
works so let's go let's look at this
[ __ ] here let me get some shoutouts real
quickness here well I got this time here
to beautiful Monday morning when the
when the beat drops full metal Pete
Justin Leo del Luke Luis Bosley Harry
Daniels and Mick Parenti and going to
Mick Phillips you bad [ __ ] and
don't forget this Saturday night I'll be
at the Ice House 7:30 working out with
uncle Joey and we had a second show at
NIACC a 10 o'clock show and lovely live
on the 21st it's all I got this
I'm getting the splint put in my ear
next week
whatever the [ __ ] it is soon yeah so is
my daughter used to have to have that
yeah cuz they got me water won't drain
it and I get [ __ ] dizzy and I come
having a hard time driving when I Drive
especially I [ __ ] get it
I'm sorry I forgot to put cream I just
went to Colorado and three days in
Colorado dried my skin up so bad this is
Mac and my wife told me she goes wrong
with your ass what he had scratches on
your ass before I go cuz I'm so [ __ ]
dry and I forgot to put cream on again
tonight look at my legs look at my skin
never gets that dry makes you wish you
to know I took a shower too tonight
after we went to the wine sale we only
went to swimming tonight okay so there
you have it there break this down I
don't know what the [ __ ] happened me and
we were in Denver on stage doing our
thing okay back a little bit no you're
good let it go and I'll [ __ ] I'll tell
em I stopped it okay right now you've
got Dominick Cruz and Dan Cormier are
arguing about this whole situation with
Jeremy and and Josh Emmett and the whole
thing is you know did it touch his head
or did it knock and that's the question
and what the funny part is is you got
damn rig a lot of stand right there stop
it right there okay he's in exactly
mechanic wise this is exactly what we
want a referee to be he's in the proper
position to try to see the big
difference is where the knee is is just
on the opposite side of the head from
where he's at
but he's in a great position in what we
call mechanically to be there so go
ahead and let that go for it
see the knee go the the question is you
know oh and they well the knee coming
coming back touches his head he's not
miss Stevens fault I agree to
hospitalize debate you referee did not
stop okay maybe this Dom and Mike I
agree it is on Dan Merkley on a theory
that that isn't a legal shot but that's
my why is it illegal it's illegal
because the fighter if when that goes
back to and I'll show you the position
where he's at as it's going forward
you'll see the fighter is on his knees
okay right now he's actually on his ass
in his leg okay but he's getting up goes
to his knees stop it right there
okay this is a grounded fighter because
any part of his body other than his
hands and feet that touched the ground
now under the unified rules that the
state of Florida is going under makes
the fighter a grounded fighter where he
legally cannot be neat or kicked to the
head you can see his entire leg is down
on the ground as far as he's got his
foot both knees are actually down he
doesn't have to have a hand on the
ground we want him to have his hands up
to protect his head and so this is a
grounded fighter that legally this knee
cannot be thrown and touch him to the
head or else it is a foul against Jeremy
Stephens the real question is is people
are asking well I think it's slid by the
side of his eyes alive so I don't think
it hit what I want you to see take a
look at his right ear you see his right
ear yes sir okay if you take a look at
my ears right now and I take these
headphones off and I I can move my head
but my ears don't flap they they stay
where they're at the cartilage holds
them rewind it again
go back go back go back just a little
bit watch his ear watch what it does go
ahead and let it go you're good watch
his right ear boom you see that your
flop yeah that's correct
tells you that there was a kinetic
energy that hit his head and caused that
ear to do that big old flapping motion
because he did get hit to the head all
right then he did hit him in the head
and it is illegal we had the referee
wasn't sure he's
but I mean these guys couldn't even get
it right watching the replay over and
over and over but they want him to get
it in real time he wasn't sure so he let
it go not stopping because he thought
I'm in a fight ending sequence and I'm
not sure but did it hit into the head
absolutely was it a foul absolutely
should there have been something done if
the referee had seen it absolutely
something should have been done it's an
illegal act it didn't hurt Josh
Emmett there was legal blows that hurt
Josh Emmett but the knee did touch and
in that situation I would have stopped
the action and gotten Josh hemming up
and given him time to recover from the
legal blows that actually did do him
damage because he did get fouled
and that lets get him back in the fight
restart because Jeremy Stephen needs to
know I can't throw a knee in this
situation what would if this me you stop
this fight put them both in that corner
take a point away from Jeremy Stephens
just started again that's what should
have been done yeah in the end though
this led to a knockout he was done after
this
yeah he ends up getting knocked out he
gets hit you know not so much with the
knee that hurts him here but he gets hit
with another punch and then he gets hit
with two huge elbows that puts him out
and then but just on the other side of
it how frustrating must it be as a
referee and as a fighter that each state
or some states different rules
ridiculous if you know you bring it it's
the most ridiculous thing that we have
going is I have commissions yeah and
this is the problem with athletic
commissions is each state is different
each tribal commission can be different
each province up in Canada is different
down in Brazil it can be different and
they all are their own little kingdom
and they don't follow what they vote on
to say all right we're going to do this
and then some will say well I didn't
like it so I'm not going to do it and
they take a professional sport like MMA
that is growing leaps and bounds the
fighters are getting better and better
and they are screwing over fighters
they're screwing over officials they're
screwing
the fans because they don't like
something and I want to be different
when they're doing everything they can
to screw over the sport of MMA the sport
that they're supposed to be regulating
and taken care of they're doing what is
the worst thing for it it's embarrassing
so right now we would have stopped this
fight let them both get up deduct the
poison and Jeremy Stephens and go right
back that's what should have happened in
yeah if you had seen if you're Dan and
you say that knee I believe that knee
touched you're gonna stop the action
you're gonna take cherami away from them
you're gonna bring a ringside physician
in I'm gonna alter things you know I'm
gonna I'm gonna work things out I'm
gonna tell the ringside position if at
all possible I want you to know that
that need did not hurt him it was legal
blows it hurt him if at all possible I
want to get him back in this fight if
you say that he can't go on then fine
we'll pull him out of the fight and I'll
make a decision what I'm gonna do
but if at all possible I want you to
tell me that he can get back in this
fight and if we can get him back in the
fight then we'll do something as far as
you know possibly taking points from
Jeremy and get the fight going again and
make sure that Jeremy knows you and look
at do you understand the position that
you can knee him in or not knee him and
I'm gonna go over this is a problem it
has happened a couple of times and it
says you know Dan's been the referee a
couple times Gegard Mousasi was fighting
Chris Weidman
in New York that position caused Dan a
problem there
okay what Gegard did was absolutely
legal everything he did was legal and a
fight was stopped
based upon damn believing that it was
illegal and that's part of it you know
you look at what goes on it's like god
same situation I'm not sure if we're not
sure we're not gonna make the decision
because I didn't see it but if I know
that I saw that knee hit that I'm gonna
stop the action and do something
different
it's in you you were saying that you
you're on your third career you you are
but I thing to you you said earlier cops
make decisions so I see make they made
you a better ref and now listening to
this I haven't watched one full Bellator
fight but I know already that I enjoy
watching a fight with you as a
commentator because you actually know
what you're talking about
that is amazing yeah it's I meant look
if there's things that I'm gonna know
that you know Joe Rogan has been
probably the best color commentator for
MMA that there's ever been Jimmy Smith
who was it with Bellator ins now with
the UFC he's phenomenal I love Jimmy Joe
Rogan set the he set the standard and it
wasn't it wasn't always so much I'm not
gonna say it was always so much the the
skill level that he brought with it as
far as knowledge but he has great
knowledge and sport it was also the
excitement and the energy that Joe
brought you know or does still bring it
just doesn't do it here so much but
that's what makes Joe who he is as far
as calling fights but there's things you
know look I've I've yelled at Joe you
know did we had a fight where we had Tim
means against Charles Oliveira and Joe
is sitting at the you know he's he's
talking with Tim means and saying I
believe that was legal when I'm looking
at a knee that I know is illegal and
it's not it's not Joe's fault that he
doesn't know it's it's our fault for not
educating him on it and making sure that
he knew because there's not only he
doesn't know there's other there's other
officials that aren't sure about that
situation and this is what's wrong with
what athletic commissions are doing to
our sport is every official every person
every fan should know what the rules of
MMA are and understand hey you're not
allowed to need someone when their knees
are on the ground to the head you can't
do that and all of that is stuff that
should be easy for people but we get
confusion about what's legal and what's
not and there shouldn't be
Joe can't know everything I happen to be
one of the guys in you
wrote this stuff and put it all together
so I know it you know inside and out you
know backwards forwards I know it all
and at least I can sometimes communicate
things to the fans so they understand
this is why the referee is doing what
he's doing or this is why that was legal
or this is why that was not legal and
they're gonna get the right information
the first time that's why I'm happy and
doing this you still doing the podcast
no man I haven't done the podcast I got
I got yelled at by people in the UFC so
just top the podcast but that was a that
might start another one right now I want
to be your partner yeah we're gonna talk
about it I'm gonna see you sit on Lido
we got it we got we got a [ __ ] called
cobalt or make them do a Bellator
tonight you know kind of like what those
books they put out for dummies you know
computer dumb they need to put it so
next next show in California want to
come too yes what is it
May 12th in my in town yeah that's when
I got to find out it's in San Jose de
that's California if you want the next
one in LA I'll get your tickets the next
one in do it I'll be in touch your units
right I wanna go I want to go down and
see it I'm happy you came on bro
thank you brother you know what's crazy
Lee I can't believe that we have Burger
King as a sponsor and I really want to
welcome
I like Burger King I like breaking up
growing up cuz I'm saying now I'm a
little older I don't need that much fast
food but if I was gonna get the chicken
sandwich I go to Burger King you know
why because they got to crispy chicken
sandwiches too or whopper sandwiches for
six dollars that's one spicy chicken
sandwich actually too spicy chickens
because right now bird can you can get
to Lou spicy crispy chicken sandwiches
just six bucks made with 100% white meat
seasoned chicken fillet a crunchy
coating with a blend of cayenne pepper
spices push fresh lettuce tomato creamy
lemon cream email served on a soft
potato bun so if you like it spicy and
you like chicken and you're like a good
deal today is the day for you
head to Burger King now and try the new
spicy chicken set new crispy chicken
sandwich you get you can get two
additional sandwiches for just six bucks
you get two spicy crispy chicken
sandwiches or mix it with the whopper
sandwich or the crispy chicken sandwich
there's six different combinations of
premium sandwiches that you can mix and
match any way you want and it doesn't
matter how you match it or mix it as
long as it's true for six dollars so the
new crispy chicken sandwich is part of
the $2 - for $6 deal all right the new
spicy crispy chicken sandwich is part of
the two for six dollar deal only at
Burger King I also want to give a shout
out to Squarespace all right listen let
me explain something there's nothing
more important to a society if you're in
business or if you're in business for
yourself than to have a website all
right you like Joey what do I need a
website I'll tell you why you probably
got a cool idea you could turn it into
something you could showcase your work
you can blog or publish content you
could sell products you could announce
an upcoming event and much much more
let me tell you some Squarespace does
something they give you beautiful
templates created by world-class design
is a powerful ecommerce functionality
lets you sell anything online the
ability to customize look and feel
settings product and more with just a
few clicks
everything optimized for mobile right
out of the box a new way to buy domains
and choose from 200 extensions now make
it yourself easily create a website by
yourself and make it stand out stand out
with a beautiful little website right
now from a Squarespace head over to
swear space.com for a free trial when
you're ready to launch use offer code
Church CH you are CH to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain that's quest based calm at the
code Church I want to thank on it for
always being there for us if you want
supplements delivered to your house go
to Hannah calm and don't forget next
Saturday the high sauce is sold out but
to follow 3:21 March 21 I'm at NIACC the
first show sold out we have this
second show so hopefully I'll see you
there Albuquerque the first week of
April we'll get to that later I want to
thank our sponsors and I want to thank
Big John there's beautiful wife for
coming in and saying a lot of us thanks
for having me but wishing you all the
luck in the world we in new position if
anybody deserves you you look beautiful
your wife looks good that's it you're in
Vegas you're a new [ __ ] man
thank you brother an hour support
Bellator now I'll watch that you're
there I appreciate you that thank you
again
Lisa at till that [ __ ] me away
[Music]